bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat poursuivre dans un instant en
direct de l'hémicycle la séance des
questions cribles une séance thématique
au cours de laquelle un ministre est
interrogé sur son domaine est
aujourd'hui un sujet au coeur de
l'actualité c'est l'avenir de la filière
photovoltaïque photovoltaïque autrement
dit de l'énergie solaire et c'est
nathalie kosciusko morizet ministre de
l'écologie qui va répondre aux questions
des sénateurs pendant 45 minutes une
filière en question une filière qui
subit même un coup d'arrêt puisque le
gouvernement a décidé de revoir à la
baisse les conditions dans lesquelles
edf rachète l'énergie produite par ceux
qui mettent des panneaux solaires par
exemple les agriculteurs sur le toits de
leurs bâtiments agricoles
tout ça pour éviter une sorte d'effet de
bulles puisqu'il ya eu une véritable
explosion de l'énergie solaire alors
hein ça coûte très cher à l'état trop
cher aujourd'hui deux ça profite aux
fabricants chinois en fait de panneaux
photovoltaïques et 3 ça pour conséquence
d'augmenter votre facture d'edf puisque
à partir du 1er janvier il y aura une
hausse de 3% de la facture tout ça pour
financer le développement du solaire
puisque edf rachète plus cher l'énergie
solaire quelle que ce que lui coûte sa
propre source d'énergie en particulier
l'énergie nucléaire bref il ya
véritablement une panne de courant en ce
qui concerne le photovoltaïque alors on
attend des sénateurs qu'il soit assez
vif pour savoir si la ministre entend
tout de même maintenir en vie cette
filière comment elle entend la relance
et dans des conditions raisonnables et
faire en sorte aussi de respecter les
engagements du grenelle de
l'environnement on retrouve tout de
suite se débat dans l'hémicycle et sera
rediffusé ce soir sur france 3 après
l'émission ce soir ou
jamais chacun des orateurs aura à coeur
de respecter sans temps de parole et ya
les chronomètres qui fonctionne à l'est
la parole est à monsieur martial
bourquin pour le groupe socialiste sur
le président madame la ministre cheikh
collègues
souvenons nous en décembre 2008 le plan
national de développement des énergies
renouvelables dans le droit fil de l'eau
ferait de l'euphorie du grenelle
affirmait sans ambages que l'état devait
jeu si dynamiser le marché de l'énergie
solaire
accélérer la recherche et bâtir une
véritable industrie du solaire en france
deux ans plus tard il s'avère que la
mise en oeuvre de ce plan a parfaitement
réussi sur un point le marché de
l'énergie solaire et de l'aveu de tous
particulièrement dynamique
oui les objectifs du grenelle ont été
atteints mais à quel prix madame la
ministre
et pour quels bénéfices collective réel
concernant le développement durable
est-ce qu'il faut tenir compte du bilan
carbone réel quand concernant
l'importation des panneaux solaires du
transport de ceux ci du recyclage de
milliers de panneaux solaires le plus
souvent de première génération
l'environnement du photovoltaïque s'est
faite sur le dos de la construction
d'une industrie française nouvelles et
innovantes et l'unc au jeu sur internet
à l'heure vers monsieur proglio en
disant que je déplorais qu edf et des
grands projets de mise en place de
panneaux photovoltaïques souvent au
détriment de la filière française qui
est extrêmement innovante
c'est à dire la filière française est en
train de mettre en place des capteurs
solaires de 2e 3e 4e génération et on
voit trop souvent des grands projets mis
en place y compris par un grand donneur
d'ordres favorisant la mise en place de
ces panneaux de première génération
alors madame la ministre le moratoire
qui était pris
doit être l'occasion d'une mise à plat
complète de ce secteur surtout
l'établissement de nouvelles règles
je pense à des aides fiscales plutôt que
d'abandonner tout est dans ce secteur
subordonner un vrai bilan carbone et
sociétal je pense à des sorties de
dispositifs d'être très progressif de
type prime à la casse comme ça se fait
dans l'automobile voilà madame la
ministre nous faisons attention nous
avons une filière très innovante qui
peut créer des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois et bien ne l'a sacrifions pas
rend l'état madame la ministre kosciusko
morizet merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur martial bourquin je
peux souscrire à l'ensemble du constat
que vous faites avec le grenelle de
l'environnement nous sommes fixés des
objectifs de volumes en matière de
développement de l'électricité
photovoltaïque
ils sont aujourd'hui en passe d'être
largement dépassé c'était mille 100
mégawatts à horizon 2012 et 5400 à
horizon 2020 nous sommes sur un rythme
qui nous conviendra à avoir des volumes
bien supérieurs
mais nous avions aussi derrière ces
volumes des objectifs les objectifs
environnementaux et des objectifs en
matière d'emploi avec le développement
d'une filière industrielle en france
et force est aujourd'hui de constater
que la façon dont s'est développé le
marché et disons le la bulle spéculative
qui s'est créée autour de l'électricité
photovoltaïque ne permet pas de remplir
ces deux objectifs sous jacent en effet
pour ce qui concerne la dimension
environnementale de l'opération un
panneau fabriqué en chine c'est de
l'ordre de 1 v veut lui fois la
consommation de co2 la production de co2
d'un panneau fabriqué en france
or aujourd'hui de mémoire sans garantie
totale sur le chiffre mais je crois que
c'est 90% des panneaux qui sont posés en
france qui sont fabriqués en chine
du côté de la qualité de la filière en
termes de création d'emplois on termes
de développement d'une filière
industrielle
des emplois se sont créés mais ce sont
les emplois d'installateurs de
raccordement d emploi service
on peut pas parler aujourd'hui du
développement d'une filière industrielle
en france c'est la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement sous l'autorité du
premier ministre a choisi de réorganiser
tout simplement l'ensemble des soutiens
au photovoltaïque il ne s'agit pas d'une
remise en cause nos objectifs du
grenelle de l'environnement qui sont
bien maintenues et réaffirmé mais il
s'agit d'atteindre toutes nos cibles non
seulement les volumes en matière
d'installation de panneaux
photovoltaïques mais aussi nos objectifs
environnementaux et nos objectifs en
matière de création d'emplois le système
est pour le moment suspendue à
l'exception des installations de moins
de 3 kilowatts heure c'est à dire grosso
modo 30 mètres carrés de panneaux
ça correspond aux installations pour les
particuliers le système est suspendu
pour trois mois le temps d'avoir une
large concertation avec tous les acteurs
et de mettre en place un système de
soutien qui nous permettra d'atteindre
nos objectifs environnementaux et nos
objectifs en matière de création
d'emplois et filières industrielles et
qui sera lui véritablement pérenne parce
qu'il faut donner la lisibilité aux
acteurs et je comprends qu après les
différentes modifications qui a eu sur
le tarif
les acteurs soient aujourd'hui dans une
situation de trouble l'objectif est bien
au mois de mars de leur donner enfin un
cadre pérenne un cadre qui corresponde
véritablement à tous les enjeux du
grenelle de l'environnement
alors pour la réplique que la parole est
à notre collègue venir raul
merci monsieur le président je vous
rappelle les discussions que nous avions
eue dans le cadre du grenelle
j'avais dénoncé déjà le bilan carbone
déplorable de la filière photovoltaïque
en tous les cas par rapport aux produits
existants sur le marché
deuxième marque j'attendais est en tous
les cas
j'attendais la création ou
l'accompagnement d'une vie véritable
filière photovoltaïque française et en
particulier à base de composés
organiques de composants organiques
ça existe il ya des expériences qui sont
faites au cea grenoble en particulier
il ya des prototypes qui sont en cours
et on pourrait profiter de ce moratoire
pour les mèdes pour les amener à la
phase bêta c'est à dire au stade
industriel
troisième remarque je voudrais vous
faire pourquoi personne ne parle du
solaire thermodynamique et qui ne pose
aucun problème au niveau de
l'environnement et il serait bien plus
simple
la parole est à notre collègue ladislas
poniatowski pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
merci mais je prévois excusez moi je
dirais c'est 2 go avec monsieur proglio
qui nous a quittés madame ministre
comment est ce que nous en sommes
arrivés là quand je dire là c'est à dire
la décision qui a été prise par le
gouvernement de suspendre l'obligation
d'achat je pense qu'il ya deux
responsables le gouvernement est en
partie responsable
les acteurs aussi le gouvernement parce
que à l'occasion du grenelle de
l'environnement même si l'objectif était
ambitieux pour 2020 a omis deux choses a
omis de fixer des quotas annuels
c'était bien un objectif pour 2020 mais
ne pas fixer des quotas annuels c'était
dangereux et puis le gouvernement ont
mis une chose alors là que plusieurs
avaient soulevé à l'époque c'était
comment est-ce qu'on finance sa et
personne n'avait répondu clairement à la
question à l'époque alors le dispositif
des ti été mis en place
est ce qu'il a été trop favorable je
suis tenté de dire non si nous voulions
rattraper nos voisins matière de
photovoltaïque
oui par contre compte tenu de ce à quoi
on assiste et c'est à dire la bulle
spéculative à laquelle on est arrivé je
rappelle en deux secondes des chiffres
on est arrivé à la fin de l'année 2009 à
ce que l'objectif 2020 soit atteint
c'est-à-dire en projet bien sûr déposé 5
4 mégawatts
le coût de ces projets est déjà pour
2009 de 60 millions d'euros pour 2010
sera probablement de
300 millions d'euros pour 2011
on atteindra le milliard d'euros ce
n'est pas de la spéculation ça c'est ce
qu'il faudra payer pour les projets déjà
déposé pour certains parlent de
plusieurs dizaines de milliards 90
milliards en 2020 alors madame la
ministre
ma question c'est c'est pas simplement
est ce que vous allez arriver à
instaurer un système pérenne
mais ce que vous allez arriver en
négociant peut être un petit peu plus
avec les intéressés n'oubliez pas qu'il
ya toute une filière industrielle
derrière a également fixé des quotas
c'est un peu tard parce que les projets
sont déjà déposées on sait que pas loin
de 10 à 15 % d'entre eux ne vont pas se
réaliser il faut mettre des quotas
jusqu'au bout et question subsidiaire
ballard ministre
si c'est un conseil que je puis me
permettre de vous donner vous feriez
bien d'établir les mêmes quotas pour
l'éolien car aujourd'hui nous parlons
d'un vrai problème économique qu'est ce
photovoltaïque je crains que le problème
se pose la même main très bien
l'apparent le terme adam la ministre
nathalie kosciusko morizet merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs aussi au
sénateur ladislas poniatowski là aussi
je pourrais se strient souscrire à
beaucoup de ce que vous avez dit
l'objectif au moment du grenelle de
l'environnement a été de lancer
rapidement le développement du
photovoltaïque en france
et c'est vrai que conjointement avec les
professionnels
il a été considéré que le tarif de
rachat tarifs de rachat qui était fixé à
l'époque à un niveau qui paraissait pas
excessif puisqu'il était sensiblement le
même dans tous les pays européens
le tarif de rachat était la meilleure
solution et c'est pas par hasard
d'ailleurs que tous les pays européens
sont trouvés confrontés au même problème
que nous est peu ou prou été amenés
aussi avoir une politique de
reconsidération de leur système de
soutien au photovoltaïque c'est qu'en
fait le prix des panneaux chinois a
baissé très rapidement et on s'est
retrouvés avec un déficit de la balance
commerciale en matière de photovoltaïque
dont je vous livre quelques chiffres
dans le prévisionnel du premier
trimestre 2010 on en aurait pour 400
millions d'euros d'un port et 100
millions d'euros d'export c'est un
déficit qui atteint 800 millions d'euros
en 2009 soit 2 % du déficit commercial
français
nous avons été amenés à reconsidérer en
flux tendu quasiment les tarifs de
rachat mais en fait c'est insuffisant
parce que comme vous l'avez souligné le
problème il est aussi celui de la
conditionnalité environnementale et de
la la conditionnalité même si ce mot
peut pas être employée de la même
manière en termes de structuration d'une
filière industrielle nationale
c'est tout l'enjeu de cette concertation
que nous lançons cette concertation que
nous lançons doit permettre de mettre en
place un système définitif de me donner
la lisibilité aux acteurs et de le faire
en prenant véritablement et manière
permanente en compte la qualification
environnementale et la qualification en
termes d'emploi j'ajoute que je suis
sensible à votre dernière remarque
et oui je n'entends pas répéter les
mêmes erreurs pour l'éolien je travaille
en ce moment sur le projet d'appel à
projets d'éolien offshore
j'ai proposé au premier ministre que
nous intégrions des conditionnalité
environnementale
nous fassions les choses de telle sorte
que le système soit favorable à la
structuration d'une filière nationale en
matière d'éolien offshore nous avons des
atouts à faire valoir sur cette filière
ne repasse ont pas parlé même sentier
d'excès que nous avons connue sur le
photovoltaïque
allez monsieur ladislas poniatowski pour
la réplique rapide
oui mais l'analyste oublie pas qu i à
iii marché du photovoltaïque il ya le
bâti des particuliers ils ont été
relativement raisonnable on n'a pas
dépassé les objectifs
il ya ce qu'on appelle les centrales au
sol menés par des industriels
là aussi on est à peu près je dirais
dans les rails ce qui a explosé vous le
savez très bien tous ce sont les projets
sur les toits que ce soit les bâtiments
agricoles les bâtiments industriels ou
les parkings comme on dit alors dans les
réponses que vous allez donner à la
suite de la négociation je crois qu'il
faut affiner les réponses tenir compte
de ceux qui ont été raisonnables et ceux
qui ont été moins parce que vont faire
les professionnels économiques puisque
ça va être fermé pour les toitures des
bâtiments agricoles industriels et ben
ils vont faire la pression sur les deux
autres marches et donc c'est les quotas
il faut les fixer sur les trois marchés
la parole et à notre collègue monsieur
michel guillou merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mais chaque
collègue nous venons de l'évoquer
l'examen de la loi de finances pour 2011
a été l'occasion de dénoncer les lacunes
et le manque de cohérence de la
politique gouvernementale en matière
d'énergies renouvelables et plus
particulièrement ce qui concerne la
production d'énergie photovoltaïque avec
la publication le 9 décembre dernier un
décret suspendant l'obligation d'achat
d'électricité pour certaines
installations utilisant l'énergie
excusez moi un radiatif solaire le
gouvernement essaie de gagner du temps
pour endiguer les effets d'aubaine des
mesures de défiscalisation et
d'obligation d'achat
en effet force est de constater que le
gouvernement n'a pas su encourager la
recherche fondamentale et appliquée dans
le secteur pas plus qu'il n'a su mettre
en place une filière industrielle de
production et de recyclage
ainsi le rapport charpin sur le
photovoltaïque de l'inspection générale
des finances
constate que 80% des panneaux installés
en france sont importés de chine
nous l'avons évoqué cette situation
conduit évidemment un déficit important
de la balance commerciale mais le bilan
environnemental est également
préoccupant vous venez de le déplorer à
nouveau madame la ministre
ces panneaux fabriqués en chine génère
par leur utilisation et leur fabrication
80 % de co2 de plus que les panneaux
français enfin la question du recyclage
des matériels en fin de vie n'est pas
suffisamment prise en compte par les
autorités publiques
la filière du photovoltaïque est récente
et ils déchets correspondant n'est pas
encore produit le sera dans 10 ou 15 ans
lors de la fin de vie des premières
installations
or aujourd'hui le photovoltaïque n'est
pas inclus dans la directive sur les
déchets d'équipements électriques et
électroniques
l'accord volontaire de collecte et de
recyclage des panneaux solaires
photovoltaïques usagers signée par plus
de 30 producteurs internationaux n'est
pas suffisant tant il est important que
les autorités publiques ne se désengage
pas de cette question et assure
notamment un contrôle strict et une
traçabilité irréprochable des produits
vous avez annoncé la ministre
constatation sur le sujet qui aboutirait
famars cependant pouvez vous nous dire
dès à présent
quelles vont être les mesures concrètes
pour assurer un traitement optimum des
déchets à venir et garantir la
responsabilité sociale des entreprises
de la filière sans pour autant amoindrir
le contrôle de l'état dans ce cadre êtes
vous favorable à mme la ministre un des
pics à sion la directive sur les deux 3e
à la filière photovoltaïque aller
jusqu'au bout merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jeu là aussi je
pourrais souscrire à pas mal de choses
que vous avez dit et notamment en
matière de recyclage
je dois reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui ce
qui est prévu en matière de recyclage
est tout à fait insuffisant les panneaux
photovoltaïques sont soumis au droit
commun en quelque sorte en matière de
recyclage et ne sont
intégré dans aucune des catégories de
type déchets spéciaux en quelque sorte
qu'ils sont qui sont qui sont prévues et
qui font que nous essayons en quelque
sorte de boucler les filières des
matériaux c'est un des sujets qui sera
pris en compte dans la concertation et
c'est un des sujets même s'il est peu
présent dans les différents échos
médiatiques dans les remarques des uns
et les autres et je vous remercie vous
de l'avoir soulevée parce que je le
considère comme très important c'est un
des sujets sur lequel je veux pouvoir
faire des propositions dès le mois de
mars en même temps que nous remettrons
en place la filière
le système de soutien dont il est vrai
que sur un sujet pareil c'est un tout
nous voulons atteindre nos objectifs en
matière de volume nous voulons atteindre
nos objectifs environnementaux y compris
la dimension recyclage nous voulons
atteindre nos objectifs en matière
d'emploi et au mois de mars
je proposerai avec mes collègues du
gouvernement un cadre global qui nous
permettront d'atteindre ces trois cibles
du même mouvement
si vous le permettez alors je ne peux
pas vous répondre précisément encore
pour savoir si nous intégrons des 3 ou
pas parce que c'est quelque chose qui
mérite plus expertise et nous
travaillons actuellement sur le sujet
donc je veux pas prendre d'engagements
précis à ce stade là dessus vous savez
comme moi qui a des inconvénients et des
avantages à être intégré dans une telle
filière
il faut se poser la question de savoir
si c'est un système particulier ou une
filière de ce type qui sera le mieux
adapté j'en profite si vous permettez
monsieur président pour dire un mot en
réponse puisque on ne peut pas nous
répondre à la réponse du sénateur
ladislas poniatowski pour dire que les
objectifs prévus pour 2012 et 2020 ont
vocation comme suivant son souhait à
être équitablement répartis entre les
projets sur toitures résidentielles les
projets sur grandes toitures et les
centrales au sol
donc cette idée d'avoir un quota ou au
moins de me cotta est un promu un
équilibre entre les différents types de
projets sera bien suivie
vous pouvez répliqué monsieur michel
billaut b rapide
monsieur le président merci madame la
ministre mais permettez moi de
d'insister sur quelques points quand
même dans la lettre de mission créant la
mission relative à la régulation et
développement de la filière
photovoltaïque en france par votre
prédécesseur celui ci demandait
d'identifier un développement pertinent
et raisonnée de l'énergie photovoltaïque
qui permettent notamment les méninges
d'émergence de nouvelles filières
industrielles créatrice d'emplois cette
demande est intervenue alors que
l'obligation d'achat d'edf existait déjà
depuis 2002 donc fort tardivement
elle est intervenue alors que le
gouvernement n'a eu de cesse de
fragiliser les investissements
productifs dans le secteur énergétique
que ce soir à travers la privatisation
de gdf ou l'obligation faite à edf de
vendre à bas prix à ses concurrents une
partie de sa production d'électricité
d'origine nucléaire
je crois qu'au lieu de promouvoir une
politique énergétique cohérente qui
assure une mixte énergétique cohérent et
efficace
le gouvernement a mis en place à kauda
citation fiscale commerciale
un système qui coûte cher à nos
concitoyens la réflexion qui va
s'engager sur photovoltaïque de manière
très sectoriel ne réglera rien si vous
n'optez pas pour la mise en oeuvre d'une
politique énergétique d'ampleur qui ne
tourne ni le dos à son industrie à sa
recherche et à l'intérêt général je vous
remercie madame la ministre
allez la parole et à notre collègue jean
claude merceron pour le groupe union
centriste
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre pour la seule année 2010 les
deux baisses successives du prix de
rachat de l'électricité produite à
partir de panneaux photovoltaïques ont
considérablement modifié les équilibres
financiers des investisseurs la semaine
dernière un décret a suspendu pendant
trois mois purement et simplement
l'obligation de rachat de l'écocité dans
nos territoires et notamment en vendée
l'instabilité de la réglementation et
l'absence de sortie en sifflet des
dispositifs menace gravement la filière
investisseurs chefs d'entreprise
salariés
la filière navigue à vue comptez-vous
prévoir un calendrier stable de la
sortie ou de la modification des
dispositifs pour donner un peu de
visibilité aux investisseurs s'il en
reste pour la période 2011 2015
à côté des investisseurs privés le
moratoire touche des collectivités
territoriales je suis président d'un
syndicat d'énergie qui regroupe
l'ensemble des communes de la vendée
nous venons en termes de procédures
exemplaire relevant du code des marchés
publics procédure contre intel hong par
définition de signer un contrat de
personnes de partenariat public privé
pour construire quatre centrales au sol
sur d'anciens centres d'enfouissement
des déchets cette opération s'est vu
décerner en octobre dernier le prix
national des partenariats public-privé
2010 une opération comme celle-ci
s'inscrit parfaitement dans le grenelle
de l'environnement
elle n'utilise aucun terrain agricole ou
constructibles
elle valait elle valorise des sols
inutilisable pendant 30 ans elle permet
d'injecter dans l'économie 42 millions
d'euros dont 20% de travaux confiés à
des entreprises locales
elle ne constitue pas une aubaine une
aubaine financière car elle ne dégage
qu'une faible rentabilité
néanmoins supportable pour un partenaire
public alors madame la ministre
au lieu de condamner l'ensemble des
projets photovoltaïques comptez-vous
discerner les opérations vertueuse des
effets d'aubaine et faire sortir du
moratoire les projets de collectivités
qui porte au niveau local la politique
environnementale du gouvernement
la parole est à mme la ministre nathalie
kosciusko morizet merci monsieur le
président de l'un des messieurs
dessinateur monsieur le sénateur claude
merceron
je comprends le mécontentement des
industriels de la fière et qui ne
seraient pas mécontents à leur place
mais pouvons-nous raisonnablement
envisager d'ici quelques années de
regarder nos concitoyens dans les yeux
et de leur dire que si la cspe qui vous
savez et la part sur la facture
d'électricité qui sert à promouvoir les
énergies renouvelables notamment si la
csp augmente c'est pour soutenir
l'industrie chinoise parce que c'est une
part de la vérité malgré tout même si ce
n'est pas toute la vérité
et même s'il ya aussi des emplois en
france je parle du photovoltaïque 1
seulement je parle pas des autres je
parle pas je parle naturellement je ne
parle naturellement que du
photovoltaïque dans ce que je dis là et
j'ajoute que nous devons aux industriels
qui se sont engagés plus de lisibilité
du fait des propres faiblesses
de notre système de soutien du fait
dépop faiblesses du système que nous
avons mis en oeuvre nous avons été
obligés de l'ajuster à plusieurs
reprises baissant le tarif et créant
ainsi une incertitude dans la filière
qui de toute façon n'était pas favorable
à son développement
donc pour la filière pour le
développement d'une vraie filière
industrielle en france pour les
consommateurs comme pour nous je crois
que nous devons faire cette cette remise
à plat
évidemment pour les collectivités
locales aussi c'est difficile et je suis
moi-même élus collectivités locales
c'est bien compliqué de se voir comme un
particulier comme une entreprise
confrontée à la remise en cause de ces
projets d'autant plus que dans une
collectivité locale il procède de la
recherche d'un consensus politique pour
autant je ne peux pas faire le tri au
profit des collectivités locales entre
les projets j'aurais aimé pouvoir faire
le tri entre les projets le plus
vertueux et les projets qui l'était
moins
ç'aurait été fragile juridiquement est
extrêmement attaquable et donc le choix
que nous avons fait et de suspendre
l'ensemble des projets de plus de trois
kilowatts
mais pendant cette période de trois mois
de travail et la concertation de telle
sorte qu'à l'issue ce sera bien les
projets les plus vertueux du point de
vue de l'environnement et du point de
vue de la constitution d'une véritable
filière industrielle française qui
surnage rond et que nous continuerons à
financer donc le tri doit se faire mais
il peut se faire qu'à l'issue de la
période de concertation le faire
d'emblée dans le décret aurait été
extrêmement accable pour la réplique la
parole et à notre collègue jean boyer
istres ma déception de ce matin puisque
j'ai posé la question à voler je suis
apparu se prolonge ce soir je vais vous
dire avec beaucoup d'objectivité qu'elle
a été alimenté plusieurs fois dans la
journée par des appels je vais pas dire
le mot détresse par mais par de grandes
inquiétudes
j'ai bien entendu les raisons qui ont
motivé
l'adaptation des dispositifs il qui ont
été comme vous l'avez dit madame le
ministre et nous connaissons ça
preuve qu'ils ont été victimes de leur
succès mais madame le ministre
gérer n'est-il pas aussi prévoir il
existe des moyens pour prévenir les
effets d'aubaine sans pour autant
condamner l'ensemble de la filière et
l'ensemble des investisseurs par une
baisse générale des montants alloués par
différents dispositifs
je voudrais évidemment si vous dire que
vous avez vous ou de vos collègues par
exemple refusé lors la discussion de
l'article 13 du projet de loi de
finances 2011 la mise en place d'un
agrément au premier euro ou encore la
mise en place de quotas même s'ils sont
un peu discutable partir d'installations
madame le ministre
il faut séparer spéculation et
production raisonnable
j'espère que vous reviendrez sûr votre
position avant de traiter le mal afin de
traiter le mal à sa source et non
seulement d'en amoindrir la douleur ne
laissons pas mourir la filière madame le
ministre
ne laissons pas mourir s'il vous plaît
réveillon là est peut-être
disons que comme noël et bientôt
essayons de le réveiller à cette époque
là
la parole est à notre collègue françois
fortin 5 pour le groupe rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le
photovoltaïque a connu un grand
développement ces dernières années du
fait de tarifs élevés à bordeaux était
d'ailleurs en 2006 de crédit d impôt en
particulier aux particuliers et depuis
le grenelle de l'environnement des
objectifs particulièrement ambitieux en
matière d'énergies renouvelables
notamment photovoltaïque
mais depuis quelques semaines de vives
inquiétudes apparaissent ici ou là
mettant en doute d'ailleurs la pérennité
de la filière baisse du prix d'achat
cela des vérités vie taux de crimes pour
diminuer de moitié dans la loi de
finances 2011 est depuis vendredi
dernier
un moratoire sur les nouveaux projets de
panneaux solaires suspension de rachat
d'électricité pendant trois mois donc
plus de demandes déposées sauf
et même si le solaire résidentiel est
épargné on a le sentiment qu'il y ait un
changement de monture au milieu du gué
qui est très désagréable pour les
investisseurs recul en plus de la
politique de développement durable
les enjeux écologiques industrielles et
économiques que sont dans une certaine
mesure sacrifiés madame la ministre quel
message voulez vous faire passer
réellement car l'on porte un coup rude à
la politique des territoires ruraux et
l'espoir de développement nos campagnes
s'évanouit
du fait de cette politique peu lisible
il faut dire la vérité aux français
madame la ministre
difficultés pour erdf pour raccorder les
cent quarante mille producteurs
production forte
le 14 juillet et le 15 août alors qu'on
a besoin d'électricité le 31 décembre et
ensuite il faut aussi signaler que le
photovoltaïque ne doit pas obérer les
terres agricoles
voilà ce que nous souhaitons madame la
ministre il nous fit une frite agréable
vous fassiez toute la lumière et la
transparence sur cette filière la parole
et arabes la ministre nathalie kosciusko
morizet merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs signature monsieur
sénateur françois fortassin là je ne
peux pas souscrire à tout ce que vous
avez dit il ya une critique que
j'entends bien et que et et que voilà
que je sais que j'accepte que je trouve
très juste qui est le manque de
lisibilité qui a pu être celui ressenti
par les acteurs de la filière et par les
investisseurs qui ont vu changer non pas
les objectifs qui eux sont maintenus
mais le système d'accompagnement vers
ces objectifs
j'insiste sur le fait que les objectifs
sont maintenus parce que dans le
grenelle de l'environnement
on a des objectifs en matière de volume
je leur dis mille 100 mégawatts en 2012
cinq mille 400 mégawatts en 2020 et puis
ses objectifs en termes de volume sont
porteur d' engagements environnementaux
et d'engagement de développement d'une
filière industrielle les objectifs en
termes de volume nous n en sommes en
passe de les atteindre
et naturellement ils sont maintenus nous
les atteindrons c'est pour atteindre
aussi nos objectifs en matière
d'environnement et nos objectifs en
matière d'emploi et de développement
d'une filière industrielle aujourd'hui
nous remettons je crois une dernière
fois en cause le cadre pour donner enfin
un cadre pérenne est visible à la
filière faisant droit ainsi à la demande
légitime des producteurs qui ont besoin
de visibilité mais pour mettre aussi en
place un cadre qui fast écho aux
exigences en matière environnementale et
en matière de création de filières
industrielles du grenelle aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
soyons clairs la façon dont se développe
le photovoltaïque en france n'y fait pas
droit
aujourd'hui nous nous apprêtons nous
sommes dans un système dans lequel la
cspe c'est à dire la contribution des
consommateurs va augmenter pour
atteindre un volume de production
d'énergie photovoltaïque oui mais au
prix d'importation de panneaux chinois
dont la qualité du cycle
environnementale si on tient compte en
particulier problème de recyclage n'est
pas assurée et sans autant d'emplois
soient créés en france qu'il pourrait
l'être s'il y avait une véritable
industrie et filière industrielle
française
nous voulons simplement atteindre trois
cibles au lieu d'une c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous nous donnons trois
mois de suspension
allez monsieur van son voisin la
rubrique j'ai apprécié l'honnêteté
intellectuelle de madame la ministre qui
nous dit il n'y a pas de visibilité dans
cette filière mais j'aurais tendance à
dire et encore et beaucoup de courtoisie
que si une filière et une politique ne
sont pas lisibles
c'est qu'elles sont pas très bonnes au
bout suivant par une question de notre
collègue dominique de legge
je pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre est cher
collègue en signant les accords
internationaux la france est engagée à
développer le recours à des énergies
renouvelables c'est dans ce contexte que
nous assistons à l'essor de l'énergie
photovoltaïque qui appelle de ma part
trois questions alors que le grenelle de
l'environnement fixe comme objectif la
limitation de la consommation des terres
agricoles
on observe une multiplication de projets
d'installations photovoltaïques au sol
consommateurs de foncier votre ministère
vient de lancer un appel d'offres pour
le développement de centrales
photovoltaïques en france qu'il prévoit
d'ici 2020 la production de samic 400
mégawatts nécessitant l'occupation de 15
mille hectares par ailleurs l'importance
distorsions de prix entre la
rémunération d'un hectares dévolus au
photovoltaïque et celui affectés à
l'exploitation agricole constitue une
véritable incitation à la réorientation
des terres vers ce type de placement je
souhaiterais connaître madame la
ministre disposition vous entendez
prendre pour trouver un juste équilibre
entre les usages agricoles et les usages
photovoltaïque deuxième observation se
pose la question de la rentabilité
financière du photovoltaïque tant les
tarifs de rachat les avantages connexes
tout laisse à penser que nous sommes
dans une bulle spéculative ou que tout
au moins nous y étions là nouvelles
donnes tarifaires affichent des écarts
arbitraire difficile d'ailleurs à
comprendre et à justifier
je souhaiterais connaître les moyens
dont dispose ou pourrait disposer la
puissance publique pour apprécier le
juste équilibre entre les incitations
offertes aux promoteurs de
photovoltaïque et la réalité des coûts
de production troisième observation la
rentabilité technique
j'ai interrogé la semaine dernière à
l'occasion du pic de consommation
électrique liée aux conditions météo les
responsables de erdf en bretagne ils
m'ont confirmé que l'anticyclone qui
accompagnent souvent les grands froids
se caractérise par une absence de vent
qui réduit à zéro la production éolienne
et que l'on ne peut trop compter sur la
production photovoltaïque c'est pourquoi
je souhaiterais savoir où nous en sommes
du projet de construction d'une unité de
production électrique au gaz dont la
secrétaire d'état à l'écologie que
j'avais interrogé sur ce sujet en
décembre 2009 avait confirmé la
réalisation pour 2012
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la ministre nathalie kosciusko morizet
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs reçu le sénateur
dominique de legge je peux vous donner
quelques chiffres qui vont accompagner
votre démonstration sur les centrales au
sol
tarif d'achat sont en effet très
incitatif 314 euros par mégawattheure
plus une prime d'ensoleillement qui peut
aller jusqu'à 20%
ceci étant à comparer au prix de gros de
l'électricité qui est de 55 euros par
mégawattheure c'est la raison pour
laquelle le développement des projets de
centrales au sol a été très dynamique en
2009 et en 2010 avec toujours
sensiblement le même type d'organisation
sont des investisseurs professionnels
qui repèrent des terrains et qui propose
un loyer en général sur vingt ou trente
ans aux propriétaires de ces terrains en
échange de l'accueil d'une centrale au
sol
la conséquence on a été une importante
distorsion des prix entre un acteur
dévolu à l'activité agricole et un
hectare dévolu à la production
photovoltaïque
tellement qu'en décembre 2009 une
circulaire a dû être envoyés pour
préciser que les terres agricoles
n'avaient pas vocation à être
transformés au profit des installations
photovoltaïques
le décret du 9 septembre 2010 va de
toute façon remettent tout ceci en cause
et entraîné l'abandon d'un certain
nombre de projets qui étaient en effet
en concurrence avec des activités
agricoles sur votre deuxième question
cette période sera aussi mise à
contribution pour évoquer l'évolution
des coûts de production de cette énergie
photovoltaïque qui sont en fait assez
différent suivant le type d'installation
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
probablement nous serons amenés à
moduler les soutiens réfléchi peut-être
même à des modalités de soutien
différents en fonction des types
d'installations enfin concernant votre
interrogations relatives au projet
d'unité de production électrique au gaz
de nombreux projets d'unités de
production de ce type sont actuellement
en cours de production je suis à votre
disposition pour évoquer tel ou tel
projet plus avant mais
nous avons des projets qui avancent
monsieur dominique de legge merci seul
président madame amis je me réjouis de
ce pragmatisme
je voudrais simplement vous dire qu'il
ya tout de même un peu urgence sur
l'approvisionnement électrique en
bretagne au moment du pic de pollution
nous avons reçu des messages très
sympathique à partir d'un système qui
s'appelle échos at on demandé aux
bretons de choisir entre le lave linge
ou la vaisselle j'espère que dans
quelques années ils pourront avoir les
deux
nous poursuivons par une question de
notre collègue monsieur serge larcher
pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre michelle collègues pour les
outre-mer le gouvernement a accepté
d'amender le coup de rabot sur la
défiscalisation de photovoltaïque prévue
initialement dans le projet de budget
pour 2011 sans défiscalisation les faits
les rendements dans ce secteur devienne
négatif car le coût des investissements
y est bien plus élevé le tarif de rachat
par edf plus faible que pour l'hexagone
les premiers se remobiliser car il
s'agissait d'empêcher de l'arrêt brutal
du développement du photovoltaïque
en attendant l'évaluation des
conséquences de la mesure de suppression
de la défiscalisation suppressions qui
va à l'encontre des dispositions de la
lodeom et des orientations du grenelle
de l'environnement sur l'autonomie
énergétique prévu parra pour les autres
merdes d'ici à 2030 et qui doit
atteindre ces camps pour cent dans dix
ans certes le développement du
photovoltaïque ne doivent pas se faire
au détriment des terres agricoles dont
on peut les lire les forêts des paysages
et des sites remarquables mais s'il ya
eu abus et surchauffe du secteur c'est
notamment parce que l'état n'a pas
publié le décret prévu par la lodeom
je vais parler du décret qui devait
freiner les effets d'aubaine a fixé un
montant maximum à houat pas projet c'est
aussi et surtout parce que nos
nombreuses l'usag ado dont je me suis
fait l'écho plusieurs fois n'ont pas été
entendues contre les dérives contre
développement anarchique des centrales
solaires
j'avais préconisé lors du grenelle 2 il
y a maintenant un meilleur encadrement
du secteur
mais un nouveau coup de pub au nouveau
coup vient d'être porté au développement
de la filière puisqu'elle serait décret
publié vendredi dernier le gouvernement
ce sport pendant trois mois lui compris
pour les outremers l'obligation de
rachat et de l'exciter produite
je n'arrête pas de changer et je crois
que l'état très mal maîtrisé les
instruments de politiques publiques
destinées à encourager la consommation
et la production d'énergie solaire
il choisit aujourd'hui de prendre des
mesures brutales christ vente au coût de
la crète au développement de secteurs
d'avenir en particulier pour le premier
ou le soleil je les lieux coup la
profusion
alors dans ce contexte madame la
ministre pouvez-vous définir les
principaux déterminants de votre
politique de développement de la filière
photovoltaïque pour les outremers tu
remercies l'interminable la ministre
nathalie kosciusko morizet c'est le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur serge
larcher c'est vrai que la filière
photovoltaïque a connu outre-mer un
déploiement depuis 2007 absolument
considérable résultant d'incitation très
avantageuses je fais suite ma réponse
précédente
outre mer c'était entre 400 et 600 euros
le mégawattheure qui était fixé le tarif
à comparer au prix de gros de
l'électricité toujours de 55 euros le
mégawattheure il ya bien sûr le crédit
d'impôt aux particuliers 50% modifié à
25% depuis septembre 2010 et puis à les
possibilités spécifiques de
défiscalisation pour les investissements
dans les entreprises localisées dans les
dom construisant les installations
photovoltaïques à l'occasion de l'examen
du plf 2011 le gouvernement et le
parlement ont décidé de supprimer les
possibilités de défiscalisation pour les
projets photovoltaïques à l'exception
des petits projets entrepris avant le 30
juin 2011 pourquoi
en premier lieu parce que la dépense
fiscale outre-mer global est passé entre
2006 et 2009 de 790 millions d'euros à
un milliard deux cent quatre-vingts
millions d'euros il faut savoir que
l'investissement dans le secteur des
énergies renouvelables concentre
aujourd'hui 40% du montant des
investissements agréés ce qui est bien
pour les énergies renouvelables mais
c'est lié à la rentabilité financière
qui est très supérieur aux autres
secteurs et ça entraîne en fait un effet
d'éviction de d'exclusion pour d'autres
secteurs qui souhaiteraient bénéficier
du dispositif
et pour l'année 2010 si on regarde
uniquement les projets photovoltaïques
relevant de l'agrément préalable
le montant des investissements pour
lequel l'aide fiscale est sollicitée
s'élève à ce jour à deux milliards 600
millions d'euros
en second lieu nous avons souhaité
supprimer cette aide fiscale pourquoi
parce que les possibilités de
défiscalisation
combiné aux tarifs d'achat très
avantageux très avantageux j'ai cités
ont entraîné un développement tels que
le nombre de projets affecte la sécurité
des réseaux électriques il y a en effet
les crises et photovoltaïque est
intermittente elle elle pèse sur le
réseau si elle a injecté en trop grande
quantité s'il ya trop grande variation
la limite technique d'intégration d'une
électricité intermittente a été fixé à
30 % de la puissance fournie or ce seuil
aura été dépassé
si tous les projets avaient été réalisés
il fallait donc agir vite c'est ce que
nous avons fait pour la suite serait
particulièrement vigilante aux
conséquences de cette décision tant en
terme de développement économique que
développement des énergies renouvelables
je reste convaincu que les îles sont un
lieu naturel favorable au développement
des énergies renouvelables mais il nous
revient de le faire de façon plus
raisonnable la réplique la parole et à
monsieur genre
bastien merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
votre réponse ne satisfait guère aux en
doutez je voudrais puisque le temps qui
m'est imparti est très court simplement
rappelé que cet arrêt brutal du
photovoltaïque va toucher plus de 2000
emplois dans les dom dans 1700 pour la
seule réunion d'hommes qui connaissent
déjà tous un chômage exponentiel
pourtant les autres maires sont encore
très loin des objectifs du grenelle de
l'environnement en termes d'énergies
renouvelables la part de ces énergies ne
dépasse pas les 2 % en martinique en est
là vraiment très loin des orientations
du grenelle qui prévoyait l'autonomie
énergétique pour l'outre-mer d'ici à
enfin je ne saurais terminer sans
insister une fois de plus sur
l'importance des installations
photovoltaïques en site isolé leur
conservation était un point essentiel
notamment pour la guyane afin que puisse
continuer à être proposé des solutions
d'électrification dans ces zones non
encore non raccordés au réseau
interconnecté douze communes sur 22 et
près de 50000 habitants un amendement
ami est adopté pour maintenir la
défiscalisation des installations
photovoltaïques dans la puissance
installée de 20 kilowatts
mais il ne s'appliquerait pas à ces
sites isolés il serait encore temps il
serait judicieux pour une réelle égalité
sur tout le territoire français que ce
point soit revue ne soit pas bloquée en
faux prétexte de terminologie la parole
est à notre collègue monsieur jean
pierre vial pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
oui à la ministre vous doutez que passe
en dernière position
je vais peut-être faire la synthèse sur
un certain nombre d'observations déjà
exprimées par certains je voudrais
peut-être ramener mon propos à des
éléments de vérité et s'il ya une chose
dont on peut peut-être se féliciter du
décret qui a été pris c'est que ce soit
une mesure de vérité pour tout le monde
le ministre y compris pour le
gouvernement vérité des coûts parce que
le photovoltaïque ne peut pas être le
bouc émissaire qu'on amène aujourd'hui
sur la place publique comme étant celui
qui est
l'origine de la hausse du coût de
l'énergie pour tous alors qu'il
représenterait un peu moins d'un pour
cent de la facture énergétique vérité
sur la lisibilité parce que sur cette
seule année 2010 ces quatre
modifications qui sont intervenus entre
la modification des tarifs
la loi de finances de 2011 et la loi
nome vérité sur la réalité économique
car ce sont plus de 15000 emplois qui
sont déjà créés sur un gisement attendue
de plus de 60 mille emplois vérité sur
les excès il y a eu effectivement des
excès sur la qualité des équipements on
doit la garantie aux usagers pour ne pas
les tromper qualité également sur les
dispositifs mis en place
nous savons madame la ministre que ce
sont plus les spéculateurs qui ont
souvent profité de des dispositifs
fiscaux mise en place que les usagers
mais également vérité sur la réalité
technologique
madame la ministre je ne peux pas
entendre que la france serait un pays
qui n'a pas profité du rebond
technologique
je le dis car nous avons aujourd'hui des
conclusions trop rapides y compris des
experts aux niveaux nationaux les
scientifiques et les chercheurs des
énergies renouvelables reconnaissent que
si l'asie est en tête des productions
industrielles la recherche européennes
et notamment françaises restent à la
pointe et des mondes déjà sa
compétitivité
ce n'est pas pour rien si l'allemagne
reste malgré les importations largement
excédentaire dans sa filière solaire ce
qui commence déjà à être le cas en
france dans le domaine des équipements
industriels
voilà la raison pour laquelle un
ministre je souhaite que le gouvernement
puisse à la suite du décret qui vient de
donner un moratoire rester fidèle aux
engagements du président de la
république qui le 9 juin 2009 10 est la
france doit être le leader des énergies
décarbonées
nous devons mettre un euro pour dans les
énergies renouvables pour un euro bittan
le nucléaire et nous devons enfin
investir pour qu'il y ait la
contrepartie des installations pérennes
en france et de la création d'emplois
voilà madame le ministre qui est attendu
du gouvernement à la suite de ce
moratoire de trois mois la parole
interminable
c'est ce que morizet merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
ce sénateur jean-pierre verts non
l'électricité photovoltaïque vous avez
raison ne doit pas devenir le bouc
émissaire de la cspe ou d'autres choses
et on se trouve forcément quand on
regarde ce sujet comme vous le savez
très bien avec les lunettes simpliste
les tarifs de rachat ont eu pour vertu
de lancer un développement qui
n'existait pas avant en france nos
concitoyens n'ont plus marqué à travers
leur leur intérêt pour les projets
photovoltaïques leur désir de s'investir
dans les projets environnementaux et
enfin oui ils ont stimulé la recherche
en france et nous avons aujourd'hui une
recherche et des développements pré
industrielle de très grande qualité pour
autant et peut-être justement parce
qu'il ya ces points positifs nous sommes
incités à faire mieux nous avons envie
que ce beau projet du grenelle de
l'environnement puissent atteint tous
ses objectifs et pas seulement
quelques-uns et nous ne serions pas à la
hauteur si au motif que les objectifs en
matière de volumes sont atteints ou que
quelques dizaines de milliers d'emplois
sont créés nous satisfaisons d'un
système qui malgré tout est beaucoup
fondée sur l'importation de panneaux
aujourd'hui de première génération et
trop peu fondée sur le développement
d'une véritable filière industrielle
non aujourd'hui vous avez raison les
crises et photovoltech n'est pas la
principale source d'augmentation la cspe
mais oui elles pourraient devenir demain
si nous ne nous réformons pas et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je crois qu'il
nous faut aujourd'hui tenir ce langage
de vérité
ce système a permis le lancement de la
filière photovoltaïque
aujourd'hui plutôt que de le modifier
tous les trois mois en adaptant le tarif
à l'évolution très rapide du prix des
panneaux chinois et sans donner
suffisamment de visibilité à la filière
nous nous donnons le temps de remettre
en place un cadre d'investissement qui
permettra d'atteindre tous les objectifs
du grenelle de l'environnement y compris
l'intégrité environnementale
la création de tous les emplois que nous
pouvons espérer avec une véritable
filière industrielle en france une
filière de très haute qualité
nous pouvons devenir le leader des
énergies décarbonées que disait le
président de la république et que vous
avez cités aller pour la réplique la
parole est à notre collègue jean paul
alduy
oui madame la ministre vous l'avez
compris à l'issue de ce débat vous avez
sur les épaules une énorme
responsabilité celle de conduire demain
de définir demain une politique stable
et des règles pérenne à l'issue ce
moratoire et qu'on arrête de décourager
une filière par des décisions
successives brutale qui modifie
profondément le modèle économique sur
lequel elle s'était développée alors ces
règles devraient en effet favoriser les
produits de demain
ces règles je vous ai entendu doivent
favoriser les projets vertueux mais où
est la vertu
on peut s'interroger j'ai entendu ici un
certain nombre de remarques et je ne
voudrais pas qu'on coup au pilori
notamment tous les projets de
sonorisation des toitures de bâtiments
agricoles de bâtiments industriels eux
bâtiments publics parce que je vous
signale qu'ils ont deux vertus un de
produire une capacité d'énergie de
production d'énergies décarbonées proche
de la consommation 2 2 nous fasse de
faciliter la mort digne la modernisation
de l'appareil industriel et agricole
donc dans dans vos réflexions prenez une
démarche globale et sachez que vous avez
au bout de votre décision
la création la disparition de dizaines
de milliers d'emplois
je forme le voeu que à l'issue de ce
moratoire
ce sera le dernier avatar de
l'encadrement fiscal est financé à riz
faire de la filière photovoltaïque bon
monsieur collègues je vais suspend la
séance et de ses entreprises à 18 heures
pour la suite
q sion de la proposition de loi de
simplification et d'amélioration de la
qualité du droit
la séance est suspendue et voilà vous
venez de suivre donc la séance des
questions cribles sujets d'actualité
consacrée à la filière photovoltaïque
après la décision du gouvernement de
prendre un décret qui institue un
moratoire de trois mois sur l'obligation
qui est faite à edf de racheter
l'électricité à ceux qui produisent de
l'énergie solaire les tout petits
projets individuels sont épargnés par ce
décret mais tout de même c'est un gel
sur le développement de l'énergie
solaire après une formidable expansion
ces deux dernières années alors vous
avez entendu la ministre nathalie
kosciusko morizet alors même qu'elle
vient d'être critiquée notamment par le
président de l'association des régions
de france le socialiste alain rousset
qui parle de décision inappropriée
inopportune vous avez entendu la
ministre dire que ce moratoire n'est pas
un coup d'arrêt au développement de
l'énergie solaire en france mais il doit
être l'occasion de définir un nouveau
cadre juridique stable à la fois pour
apporter un certain soutien à ceux qui
vont se lancer dans le solaire parce que
ça fait partie des objectifs du grenelle
de l'environnement
et puis également pour essayer de
développer une filière industrielle
française au moins européenne alors que
les panneaux solaires de première
génération sont très largement importée
de chine ce qui a fait que les
subventions versées en france à
l'énergie solaire sont en fait venus
enrichir les industriels chinois donc si
l'on fait confiance à la ministre de
l'écologie il y aura bien un après
moratoire avec un nouveau cadre
juridique et financier pour le
développement du solaire mais vous
l'avez entendu de la part d'un certain
nombre de sénateurs il ya aussi une
déception un scepticisme et des
inquiétudes sur les emplois qu'ils ont
pu être créés dans ce secteur dans le
bâtiment des travaux publics il y à des
métiers spécialisés dans l'énergie
solaire et qui sont menacées en
particulier dans les départements
d'outre-mer vous avez entendu la
remarque d'un des parlementaires
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle sur ce
sujet voilà donc un sujet
d'actualité aux enjeux à la fois
écologique et financier traiter
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de ces
questions cribles n'oubliez pas à 19h
votre rendez vous avec michel grossiord
et ses invités et puis la retransmission
de l'intervention que foire à françois
fillon à matignon où il réunit les
parlementaires députés et sénateurs de
l'ump sur la feuille de route du
gouvernement pour l'année à venir avant
l'échéance présidentielle
et puis bien sûr votre rendez vous avec
toute l'actualité à 22h ce soir et un
débat sur la nouvelle taxe google mal
nommé mais elle institue un prélèvement
de 1% sur tous ceux qui viennent faire
de la pub sur internet du coup les chefs
d'entreprise du net sont un peu
désespérée de ce disque c'est vraiment
un coup d'arrêt aux enfants tout cas un
coup de frein encore une fois à toutes
les jeunes entreprises qui essaye de se
développer en utilisant le média
internet on sera notamment avec le
sénateur philippe marini qui était à
l'origine de cette taxe dite taxe google
voilà ça ce sera à 22h sur public sénat
voilà sur le programme de la journée
tout de suite donc la suite de vos
émissions sur la chaîne parlementaire
très bonne fin de journée